Another feature that comes along
with template literals, or
template strings, is the ability
to tag them. What that means is
that we can essentially run this
through a function, and rather
than have the browser put in the
variables for us, we can have
control over how this actual
string is made. I'm going to
show you some examples of when
that would actually be useful in
just a second. For now, let's
look at the mechanics of it and
how it all comes together. The
way the tag template works is
you simply make a function. I'm
going to call this "highlight,"
and you take the name of the
function that you want to run
against the string, and you just
put the name right in front of
the template. This is tagging
it with a function name. What's
going to happen is that the
browser is going to run this
function, it's going to provide
it with all the information
about the string, all the pieces
that the person typed, as well
as the variables that get passed
in. Whatever we return from this
function is what sentence
actually is going to be. Sort
of like a step in between.
Before this function actually
gets put into here, we have the
ability to modify it in any
given way. Let's take a look at "
highlight" here. If I just
return "cool," that is going to
take in this entire string, and
then just return the word "cool."
Now we see "cool" being console.
log. Obviously, that's not what
we want to do, just replace the
entire string, but this function
will take in strings, and it
will take in the actual values.
In this case, we're passing name
and age. Now, we could do this.
It passes a name and passes an
age, but if you don't know
exactly how many values someone
is being pulled in, there's no
way for you to...you could say,
Arg1, Arg2, go through all the
way to Arg100, just in case
there are a hundred arguments,
but that's no way to live your
life. We can use ES6 rest
operator, which is three dots.
We're going to go into that a
lot more in a future video, but
know for now, if we do dot, dot,
dot values, what it's going to
do is it's going to take the
rest of the values that are
passed to that argument, and put
them into an array for us. I'm
going to pop a debugger in here,
and what that will do is it's
going to stop my function from
running. You see it, it just
opened my DevTools here. This
shows us a couple of things.
First of all, the local scope of
this function has -- obviously
this, which is a window so it's
not important -- it has strings
and it has values, strings and
values. What is strings?
Strings is an array of three
things. "My dog's name is," and "
he is, years old." What are
those? It breaks up the string
into the biggest pieces it can
until a variable has interrupted
it. We've got, "My dog's name is,"
then it pops in a variable, and "
he is," that's the second item
in the strings array, and then, "
years old." Those are the three
strings that don't get changed.
The other things we get is an
array of values, which we passed
in two values here. We get "
Snickers," and "100." That's
what I passed in, I passed in "
Snickers" and "100." Those are
the values that get passed in.
This array of strings is always
going to be one bigger than the
actual values array. Even if I
were to put in another variable,
like transgender, male, dog, if
I were to just put the gender
right at the end of this
template string, even though
there is nothing after it, watch
this. Look, it gives you an
empty string at the end and then
three. Again, strings array is
always going to be one longer
than the actual values. The idea
behind this is that, we can use
this function to build the
string ourself rather than
relying on the browser to do it.
I'm going to get rid of our
gender variable here, get rid of
this variable here, and get rid
of the debugger. Now, we need
to create a string. I'm going to
make an empty string. I'm using "
let" here, why because we're
going to be tacking things on to
this actual string. If I used
console, I wouldn't be able to
tack onto it. Then, we want to
loop over this first strings
array here, tack on "My dog's
name is," and then the first
value, and "he is," and the
second value, and then "years
old," and then third value. In
this case, we don't have a third
value. You can use whatever
loop you prefer to do. You could
even use a map and then join it
together. I'm going to use the
dot for each, so let's say
strings dot for each. We got two
things here, we get the string
and we get the index of the
actual element here. We are
going to say string, str+=,
we're going to concatenate on
what we have, strings or string+
values  . That's going
to say, give me the first value
from the strings and the first
value from our values array and
tack them on. We're going to hit
a little bit of an arrow, but if
we return this string that we've
been tacking things onto, we
should now see "My dog's name is
Snickers and he is 100 years old,
undefined." First of all,
that's because the strings array
is always going to be one larger
than the values array. When we
hit that last one, it's only
going to be a string and there's
going to be no value to tack on
the end. You could check if
values of I is undefined and, if
it is, then don't put it on. A
little trick you can do here, is
you can use your values of I or
just a blank string, and that
will adjust if there is no
values of three, then it will
just return a blank string there.
There, that's nice. Now, what
can we actually do with this?
Well, we could change this so
any value that gets passed in
gets wrapped in a spin and we
can use CSS to highlight it. You
maybe want to show your user
which pieces of the string were
variables or which pieces of the
string that they passed in,
maybe it's their user name or a
total for our order. In our case,
we just want to highlight the
name and the actual age. I'm
going to duplicate this, I'm
going to use template tags
instead of concatenation here,
and we want to pop in the string,
which is going to be the first
part. We want to give ourselves
a span with the class of "
highlight," or "HL" and inside
of that, we'll say "values I,"
or nothing. We can get rid of
all this concatenation here, I
think that's a little bit nicer.
That's our old one, we don't
want that, sayonara. We've got a
span. Now, let's see what our
sentence looks like here. There
we go. We've got a span with a
class of HL wrapped around every
single possible one. We've got
a little bit of a weirdness
going on here, because that's
the end one, but I don't think
that will be an issue. If we go
into our head here, and give
ourselves a style tag, our HLs
are going to be background,
yellow, favorite yellow in the
world, beautiful. We want to pop
this actual sentence onto the
body, document.body.enterhtml=
sentence. I got, "My name is
Snickers, and he is 100 years
old," being highlighted. You can
go ahead and maybe make those
content editable, so that if the
user didn't like it, they can
change the value they actually
wanted, they didn't like "he is
a hundred years old," they could
change that value as well. It's
kind of a fun way to do it.
There are much more complicated
use cases for that. There are
much more in depth use cases for
that, but that is the main idea
behind these template tag
templates, is that you have a
string, you pass in the regular
string that you want, and then
you get all the pieces. It's up
to you to craft it together and
to return some sort of modified
data. In our case, we're
wrapping it in a spin, but you
may want to format it or do some
if statement and conditional
work on all the values.